Like a boss.
I've been watching bloodline.
I'm up to episode eight,
season three.
I got two more episodes to go.
That show.
That series is gut wrenching.
Like I can only watch two of them and then I have to shut it off.
And I,
I've never watched the show where I get so mad at the characters,
you know?
I guess so fucking mad.
Like why the fuck did you just do that?
Shut up,
stop talking.
All of that stuff.
Most of it's what the Kevin Character.
MMM.
And
he's,
he's just lying on the floor and I,
I don't think he's crazy.
Stop talking
fast.
Your favor.
Judo.
Norbert Leo Butz,
one of like five people who ever won the best lead male Tony Award.
MMM.
These amazing fucking actress.
So anyways,
there's a guy on that show who plays Eric O'bannon,
who's absolutely killing it.
His name is Jamie Mcshane.
And for breaking bad fans,
if you are wondering,
how do I know that guy's face,
why would his face fucking make,
what am I,
how do I know that guy?
If you're a breaking bad fit the episode,
I'm not going to give anything away.
The one that involved the train.
All right.
I can't remember.
He played the conductor or the engineer.
[inaudible]
thank God you guys want to sleep with the switch.
Be like pancake study out here.
What's the trouble with it?
No clue.
I just driving down the road off the old couches bellied up and died on me.
Hey,
don't want you guys know financials.
How could she do?
That's why they call you an engineer,
right?
Get in there.
Give it a whirl.
All right,
let me give it a try.
And uh,
he was a great fucking guy and in his work on this show is fucking unbelievable.
I Dunno,
I want to quote his lines,
but I want everybody,
like when they watch movies,
it's like years later.
Do you know my dad just saw it like I did this movie called stand up guys and he
calls me up.
You like Christ fail.
Yay.
I tell you,
you,
yeah.
At night I'm sitting there,
I'm like,
I'm like narcoleptic I'm falling asleep on the couch.
I wake up at three in the morning and I'm watching this movie and a,
and I'm already laughing cause I know it's gonna be some shit I did like fucking
10 years ago.
Just your pain,
the fishies
fishies all night long.
Oh Geez.
My mistake
you,
it's got an output cheeto and Christopher Walken and I'm watching the movie
and all of a sudden there you are.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
You look at these guys.
Paul,
look at him.
They're trying to close
your fucking shopping.
What do you mean?
What?
Is there something else you're supposed to be doing?
Oh,
sorry.
Please.
Before you do this,
there's one thing you should know.
He wakes up.
My mother goes,
Hey,
this crisis.
Okay.
That's all my parents paid attention in my career.
They watch shit that I did.
It goes there was a great movie.
Yeah.
I'll tell you bill,
you know you could do this comedy stuff.
You could do the dramatic shit.
Gay fucking got it all figured out.
That's what he said.
You could do the dramatic shit.
It's my favorite thing anybody said to me all week.
Yeah,
you could do the dramatic shift.
I'm not talking to you.
Look,
you have to,
I guess not to say I should've said a long time ago.
It's just
sometimes I have problem.
Sam,
what's in my heart?
I love you more.
I love you more than the Celtics.
So anyways,
two thumbs up from my dad for a,
the fucking standup guys.
Check it out if you get a chance.
Um,
anyways,
Jamie McShane is fucking kill everybody's killing it on that show.
And then also,
uh,
John Leguizamo.
I mean,
has that guy ever been bad at anything?
Yeah.
What happened though?
You
talk to him.
[inaudible] me love you long time.
He told you why I don't understand any of your tiny,
he's fucking eat everything he's in.
He makes it better.
The guy's fucking unreal.
And
he's like creepy and hilarious all at the same time.
Polish to man.
Come on man.
You want to come?
Wow.
I'll did.
I don't give a shit.
Nobody looking.
Come on.
I want to get into it.
Come on,
I'll pull it out though.
I don't know how you'd do that unless you're a fucking genius.
Like that guy.
There's this scene.
Um,
uh,
how do I do?
I don't want to fucking ruin it for people.
He goes in and he orders like a,
what we used to call like a slurpee or a frosty,
when one of those seat orders,
one of those,
it's one of the funniest fucking scenes I've seen in a long time.
Hey,
that,
um,
that polar freeze,
is that,
is that the one that turns your tongue all blue?
What was that?
Yeah,
probably,
um,
just start watching bloodline and I'm telling you,
if you,
if you want to not have your insides get fucking all twisted up,
just you do two episodes at a time.
Um,
[inaudible]
[inaudible].